ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL WITH SO --
TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE --
BURKE [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
COLLEAGUES TO A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AT OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RICE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BAR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG
BY SENATOR MONNING.
BUT A CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
GOD OF AFFECTION DEVOTION AND
TENDERNESS.
WITH THANK YOU FOR THE MYRIAD
WAYS THIS WE HAVE BEEN TOUCHED
BY YOUR LOVE.
LAUGHTER DRAWS SAYS TO
FRIENDSHIP AND FIDELITY.
LOVE THAT LEADS US TO KINDNESS
AND COMPASSION.
LOVE THAT LURES US TO THE SACRED
AND SERENE.
LOVE THAT CALLS US TO NEW VISION
AND EVOLUTION.
LOVE TO SEIZE THE VALUE OF EACH
HUMAN BEING.
SOURCE OF ALL LOVE WE THANK YOU
FOR A BITING AND OUR HEARTS.
YOU THE ONE GREAT HEART OF OUR
UNIVERSE.
HOLDING US ALL AND THE MYSTERY
OF YOUR PRESENCE AMEN. TWO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL [inaudible] FIVE
I DON'T SEE SENATOR NUMBER Q..
SENATOR WILL CAUSE HERE I FOR A
GOOD.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES WE ARE AT PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR I BELIEVE SENATOR
WILK YOU HAVE.
A PRESENTATION AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK IF WE WOULD ALL PLEASE GIVE
OUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR WILK.
AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
CENTER WILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
BAKING MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS.
TODAY YOU WILL NOTICE UP AT THE
DAIS WE'RE FLYING THE FLAG OF
ARMENIA.
THIS MORNING TO ON HONOR THE
CONSUL GENERAL OF ARMENIA THAT
RESIDES IN LOS ANGELES
AMBASSADOR ARMENIAN.
BY BOOTIE AND STARTED HIS TENURE
AS CONSUL GENERAL IN SEPTEMBER
OF LAST YEAR.
PRIOR TO THIS POSTING HE TAUGHT
POLITICAL SCIENCE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MASSACHUSETTS
AMHERST IN A YEAR OF ON STATE
UNIVERSITY.
AND SERVED IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
IN ARMENIANS FOREIGN SERVICE
INCLUDING AN APPOINTMENT AS
AMBASSADOR TO INDIA.
NEPAL.
SIR LANKA IN INDONESIA.
OUT OF ARMENIA WAS WHEN THE
FIRST REPUBLICS TO BREAK AWAY
FROM THE SOVIET UNION IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES.
AND HE WAS A VERY FIRST DIPLOMAT
TO SERVE.
HAS CONSUL GENERAL IN LOS
ANGELES FROM NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE TO NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN SO
WE ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME HIM
BACK.
IN ADDITION TO ITS CURRENT
COUNSELOR RESPONSIBILITIES HE
ALSO SERVES AS A SENIOR ADVISER
TO THE PRINCETON FOUNDATION FOR
PEACE AND LEARNING.
AS A MEMBER OF THE YOU IN
ASSOCIATION OF THE U. S. IN AS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE GLOBAL
RESEARCH FORUM ON DIASPORA IN
TRANCE NATIONALISM IN NEW DELHI.
IN RECENT YEARS ARMENIA IS
GAINING A REPUTATION AT AS IN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY HUB.
LIKE CALIFORNIA THE ARMENIAN OUR
THE ARMENIAN.
AYE TWO SECTORS CRUCIAL FOR THE
WELL BEING OF THEIR ECONOMY.
ANSWER BURGEONING HIGH TECHS
ECONOMY MATURES.
CALIFORNIA AND ARMENIA HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP FURTHER
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
WHILE THE UP PEOPLE'S OF THE
TWENTY CENTURY HAVE BEING AN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO THIS
COUNTRY ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THIS COUNTRY.
THE FIRST ARMENIAN IN AMERICA
WAS ACTUALLY MARTIN THE ARMENIAN
WHO IMMIGRATED TO THE COLONY
VIRGINIA IN.
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN EVER SINCE
ARMENIANS HAD BEEN AND IT
ENCIRCLE PART OF OUR NATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
AS YOU MAY KNOW LOS ANGELES HOME
TO THE LARGEST ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF ARMENIA IN
FACT 40% OF THE ARMENIAN
DIASPORA IN THE UNITED STATES
RESIDES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY
IS NOT JUST LIMITED TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN FACT FRESNO HAS
BEEN HOME TO A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF ARMENIAN SINCE LATE
NINETEENTH CENTURY.
AYE MEANS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
RICHLY TO ALMOST EVERY ASPECT OF
CALIFORNIAN LIFE.
PARTICULARLY POLITICS MOST
NOTABLY GOVERNOR GEORGE
DEUKMEJIAN.
WHO SERVED TWO TERMS AS GOVERNOR
FROM?
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
NINETEEN NINETY ONE I'D LIKE TO
EXTEND MY BEST WISHES FOR
AMBASSADOR BUT BY BOOTY AND AND
HIS RENEW TENURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
I ALONG WITH I'M SURE ALL OF YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM.
TEND TO NURTURE THE GOODWILL AND
FRIENDSHIP THAT EXIST BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND ARMENIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A WARM WELCOME
EVER.
GAS DR ARM IN THE BOOTY AND A
VERY WARM.
WELCOME [inaudible]
YEAH.
STERN.
ON THIS ITEM.
JUST A VERY BRIEF --
WARM CONGRATULATIONS WELL ADDING
ON TO THE MY SENATOR FROM SANTA
CLARITA AND YEAH TOOK A TRIP TO
ARMENIA OVER THE FALL IN
INCREDIBLY VIBRANT.
DEMOCRACY OVER THERE LET OF
VELVET REVOLUTION THAT WAS
BLOODLESS AND DRIVEN BY YOUNG
PEOPLE AND ENTREPRENEURS IN
TECHNOLOGY AND ESPECIALLY WOMEN.
ABOUT 35% OF THEIR TECH WORK
FORCES WOMEN WE HAVE WE HAVE
ROOM TO MAKE UP IN THAT REGARD
ABOUT 3% OF OUR SO --
TO THEIR LEADERSHIP --
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE
ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
pTHROUGH THE FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
SENATOR UMBERG UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTION TO NOTICES --
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
REQUEST TO MOVE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AS C. R. SEVEN TO THE INACTIVE
FILE THANK YOU THANK YOU THERE
WILL BE NOTED.
UNDER INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST
READING SOME BILLS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE OH FOUR THREE
OH FIVE THREE OH SIX AND SENATE
BILL.
THREE OH SEVEN UNDER
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
UNDER THE SECOND READING FILE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION.
SIXTEEN SECOND READING IS TEAM
COMPLETED.
WE WILL RETURN COLLEAGUES TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE TIME TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
UNDER.
A JOURNEY IN MEMORY ARE THERE
ANY WE HAVE SENATOR STONE.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE AT THE POINT OF
CHURNING IN MEMORY OF THE PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
GOOD MORNING MEMORY MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ASK YOU AND
JOINING ME IN THE CHURNING THE
MEMORY OF ERIC DONNA WHO.
A YOUNG MAN IN THE PRIME OF HIS
LIFE WHO SADLY BECAME THE LATEST
VICTIMS OF THE HEROIN CRISIS
KILLING THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR IN FACT.
OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES DIED OF DRUG
OVERDOSES MORE THAN WE LOSS IN
THE VIETNAM WAR.
ERIC WAS JUST TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
OLD.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO HE MOVED TO TO
MACULA WTH THIS FAMILY BECAME A
STAR ATHLETE PLAYING WATER POLO.
HE WAS ALSO AN ACADEMIC ALL
AMERICAN AND ENDED UP GRADUATING
FROM CAL LUTHERAN UNIVERSITY
[inaudible]
SADLY.
DRUGS TOOK HOLD AMERICA BUT FOR
A WHILE HE WAS ABLE TO CLEAN UP
AND EVENTUALLY BECAME A HOUSE
MANAGER IN SAINT PAUL'S.
SOBER LIVING CENTER COLORADO AND
SERVED AS AN A A SPONSOR.
BUT LIKE THOUSANDS OF OTHER
PEOPLE ADDICTED TO HEAR WHEN HE
FELL BACK INTO THE JAWS OF A
MONSTER.
THAT HAS DESTROYED THE LIVES OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
OUR KIDS NEED TO KNOW THE HAIR
ONE IS THE MOST ADDICTIVE DRUG
OUT THERE.
IT ONLY TAKES ONE TIME ONE HIT.
TO BECOME ADDICTED AND WE NEED
TO REALLY GO AFTER THE DRUG
PUSHERS AND DEALERS WHO STEAL
OUR CHILDREN.
AWAY FROM THE WORLD.
ERIC'S DEATH SHOULD BE REMINDER
TO ALL OF US THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO KEEP HER WHEN AND FAT NO
OFF THE STREETS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF A
YOUNG MAN WHO WAS KILLED TOO
SOON.
I'M HOPING THAT WE ALL REMEMBER
THAT WE HAVE THE POWER TO DO
MORE TO STOP THIS EVIL DRUG FROM
DESTROYING ANALYZE.
I HOPE WE HAVE THE RESOLVE TO
TAKE ACTION.
DOING NOTHING IS AN INSULT NOT
JUST TO ERIC DONNA WHO.
BUT IS AN INSULT TO THE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
NEEDLESSLY DIED BECAUSE OF THE
DEALERS.
WHO SELL THIS DANGEROUS DRUG TRY
CHILDREN?
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TURN IS MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE AND IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HIM AND OF COURSE
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY
[inaudible]
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A GREAT INDIVIDUAL.
DOCTOR MICHELLE KING WAS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO
LEAD LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
ON FEBRUARY SECOND DOCTOR
MICHELLE KING LOST HER
COURAGEOUS BATTLE TO CANCER.
AT THE TENDER AGE OF FIFTY SEVEN
DOCTOR KING WAS BORN ON MARCH
NINTH NINETEEN SIXTY ONE TO
PROFESSIONAL PARENTS.
WHO WERE BOTH A PART OF A PROUD
A SPARRING BLACK MIDDLE CLASS IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WERE
MEAN SOON AND EXPECTED?
YOU WOULD GO TO COLLEGE KING
TOLD THE TIMES IN A IN A RECENT
INTERVIEW MY FATHER LOOKED AT MY
REPORT CARDS DAILY --
WE WERE TAUGHT TO RESPECT OUR
TEACHERS AND THAT WE WOULD COULD
GET GOOD GRADES HE ATTENDED LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
INCLUDING PALISADES HIGH SCHOOL
WHERE SHE WAS A TOP STUDENT.
AND A CHEERLEADER AND ONE A FEW
AFTER AMERICAN STUDENTS --
IN THAT STUDENT BODY WORK MAINLY
THE STUDENT BODY BODY WAS
WEALTHY AND WHITE.
DR KING HELD A BACHELOR'S OF
SCIENCE DEGREE IN BIOLOGY FROM
UCLA A MASTERS IN ADMINISTRATION
FROM PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY AND A
DOCTORATE OF EDUCATION FROM USC.
AND SHE ALSO RECEIVED HONORARY
DOCTORATE OF HUMANE LETTERS ARE
FROM PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY AND
LOYAL OF MIRAMONTE UNIVERSITY.
AFTER ATTENDING UCLA SHE WAS BY
HER FIRST TEACHING ASSIGNMENT
WAS IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
HE MOVED.
TO TEACHING JOBS AT PORTER
JUNIOR --
HIGH SCHOOL AND RIGHT MIDDLE
SCHOOL WHILE SHEPHERDING HER OWN
THREE DAUGHTERS THROUGH THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THE FIRST TIME KING WAS OFFERED
A PRINCIPAL JOB HOW MUCH IN HIGH
SCHOOL SHE TURNED IT DOWN.
WHEN SHE WAS FINALLY TOOK THE
JOB -- IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO AFTER BEING
PROMOTED FROM VICE PRINCIPAL THE
ENTIRE FACULTY GREETED HER WITH
A STANDING OVATION.
KING DID NOT DISAPPOINT PULLING
TOGETHER CAMPUS PORN BY DISCORD.
AFTER SHE TOOK CHARGE COUNT
UNTIL SCORE SEARCH WELL PAST
ANNUAL IMPROVEMENT TARGETS AS
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT UNDER
SUPER SUPERINTENDENT JOHN DACEY
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN SHE
FIRMLY LEAD TO EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS AFTER FATAL CRASH
KILL FIVE STUDENTS.
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SELECTION TO SUPERINTENDED OUT
DISTRICTS RANK AND FILE.
SHE OFTEN STATED AS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE
SUPERINTENDED.
I'M ABLE TO SEND A CLEAR
PERSONAL MESSAGE TO STUDENTS
THAT NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE WHO
YOU ARE AND WHERE YOU COME FROM
YOU SHOULD DREAM WITHOUT LIMITS.
IF YOU STUDY AND YOU WORK HARD
YOU CAN ACHIEVE THOSE DREAMS HE
CLEARLY PROVE THAT.
AND WILD.
WHILE DOCTOR CHAU KING NEVER HAD
A CHANCE TO LEAVE HER MARK AS A
SUPERINTENDENT WE KNOW THAT YOU
SEATED EXPECTATIONS IN EVERY
STEP OF OUR LIVES.
SOME OF THE MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WAS THE HALL OF FAME --
AFTER AMERICAN HALL OF FAME IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN FORD
OUTSTANDING --
CHEAP IN IN EDUCATION FROM LOS
ANGELES A CITY HALL CELEBRATION
THE RECIPIENT OF THE Y. W. C.
A.'S.
PHENOMENAL WOMEN AWARDS.
RECOGNIZING TOP FEMALE
EXECUTIVES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHE WAS FEATURED IN
ESSENCE MAGAZINE AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN NAMES
NATIONAL SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
YEAR BY THE NATIONAL SOLUTIONS
OF SCHOOLS.
AND SHE WAS HONORED BY UCLA WITH
THEIR WORK A DIXON ALUMNUS OF
THE YEAR AWARD JOINING SUCH
LUMINARIES AS JOHN WOODEN YVONNE
BRATHWAITE BURKE AND ARTHUR ASHE.
KING IS SURVIVED BY HER THREE
DAUGHTERS HER PARENTS AND HER
BROTHER I HUMBLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DOCTOR
MICHELLE KING A TRUE TAIL
BLAZER AND A COLLABORATIVE AND
INNOVATIVE LEADER.
WHO BROKE DOWN BARRIERS TO
CREATE MORE EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES EDUCATION FOR
EVERY STUDENT THANK YOU?
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD ON
THIS TO TURN IN MEMORY.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT --
I TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENA IN ASKING THAT WE GERMAN
IN MEMORY OF DOCTOR KING.
MICHELLE SAW THAT.
EVEN WHEN GIRLS DISPLAY AN
INTEREST IN STEM CAREERS THESE
DREAMS ARE OFTEN DISCOURAGED OR
FORGOTTEN OVER TIME DUE TO LACK
OF SUPPORT OR EXPOSURE. TO STEM
ROLE MODELS IN RESOURCES AND SO
SHE PUSH VERY HARD FOR THE FIRST
ALL GIRLS LA YOU WITH THE SCHOOL
THE GIRLS ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY KNOWN AS GALA.
SHE KNEW THE GIRLS.
THE GIRLS SCHOOLS GRADUATE GIRLS
AT THIRTY FOR RULES THING THEIR
GRADUATES TO COLLEGE AT A 50%
HIGHER RATE AND PRODUCE
GRADUATES SIX TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO GO INTO STEM COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
AND SO SHE HELPED GIVE THE GIRLS
A GALA A BETTER CHANCE AT
ACHIEVING THEIR DREAMS IN HONOR
OF THE SHELVES HARD WRK IN
LEADERSHIP GALA HAS NOW BEEN
RENAMED.
THE GIRLS ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY DOCTOR MICHELLE KING
SCHOOL OF SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATH.
MICHELLE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT A
STUDENT'S GENDER RACE OR ZIP
CODE SHOULD NOT DETERMINE THEIR
FUTURE.
WHEN SHE WAS CONSIDERING A
PROGRAMMER POLICY HER PRIORITY
ALWAYS WAS WILL THIS HELP KIDS
LEARN?
AS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN SERVICE LA YOU WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT HE KNEW THAT HER
RESPONSIBILITY WAS NOT A SMALL --
ONE SHE WORKS HARD TO ENSURE
THAT SHE LEFT A LASTING LEGACY.
SHE WAS A MENTOR AND FRIEND TO
STUDENTS COLLEAGUES AND PARENTS
AND SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED AS AN
INCREDIBLE EDUCATOR.
WE ASK YOU TO JOIN IN HER MEMORY
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL AND
OF COURSE THE PEOPLE OF LOS
ANGELES AND IN THE WHOLE STATE
HAVE LOST.
A GREAT CHAMPION.
ANY OTHER A GERMAN IN MEMORIES
WITH RESPECT TO US THIS SAID DR
KING.
REFERENCE HERE THE INTERNAL
MEMORY.
SHE NON PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
HER.
MEMORY BY MAKING SURE WE HAVE
HER NAME.
BROUGHT FORTH TO THE DESK.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO BRIEFLY
GO BACK --
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MAN
PRESENT CENTERS I JUST WANT TO
OF A WILL GIVE A WARM SENATE
WELCOME TO LILY MARTINEZ.
HIS DAUGHTER OF ON MY STAFF
PEOPLE'S COMING INTO WORK TODAY
WITH THAT HER MOTHER.
A WARM WELCOME. FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN GOING BACK
NOW TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
I BELIEVE SENATOR ATKINS FLOORS
YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO A JOURNEY
IN MEMORY OF DR WALTER MONK OF
SAN DIEGO WHO PASSED AWAY.
ON FEBRUARY EIGHTH AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF A HUNDRED AND ONE DOCTOR
MONTH WAS A BRILLIANT KIND
HEARTED MAN AND ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL GEOPHYSICIST.
AND OCEANOGRAPHERS OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY.
BORN IN VIENNA AUSTRIA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN HE CAME TO
THE UNITED STATES AT FOURTEEN
YEARS OF AGE TO WORK AS A BANK
RUNNER IN NEW YORK CITY.
BUT TO AMERICA'S GREAT FORTUNE
HE FINANCE WAS NOT HIS PASSION
ANY SET OUT FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
TO PURSUE A DEGREE IN PHYSICS AT
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF
TECHNOLOGY.
HE BECAME A U. S. CITIZEN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE AND THAT
SAME YEAR APPLIED FOR A SUMMER
JOB AT SCRIPPS INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY.
AT THE TIME A LITTLE KNOWN
ORGANIZATION AND THE REST REALLY
IS HISTORY.
SEEING THE RISE OF FASCISM
ACROSS EUROPE IN THE RISING
TENSIONS THAT WOULD SOON DRAW
THE NATION INTO WAR HE ENLISTED
IN THE U. S. ARMY SERVING IN THE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX FIELD
ARTILLERY. FORTY FIRST DIVISION
AT FORT LEWIS WASHINGTON.
BUT ONE WEEK BEFORE THE ATTACK
ON PEARL HARBOR HE WAS RECALLED
FROM HIS UNIT. TO SERVE HIS
COUNTRY AT THE U. S. NAVY RADIO
AND SOUND LABORATORY IN SAN
DIEGO IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
POINT LOMA.
NOW FROM THAT LAB HE DID MORE
FOR THE US WAR EFFORT THAN ONE
SOLDIER EVER COULD HAVE MANAGED
ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND THIS IS A GREAT STORY.
HE HUMBLY REJECTED THE
COMPARISON --
HE'S OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE
EINSTEIN OF THE OCEANS AND
THAT'S THE TYPE OF IMPACT HE
MADE WITH HIS RESEARCH HE
FUNDAMENTALLY REDEFINED OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF OCEANS.
PIONEERING NEW METHODS TO
MEASURE AND FORECAST OCEAN
CURRENTS TIDES AND TEMPERATURES.
AMONG HIS MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
HE'S CREDITED WITH SAVING THE
LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN
SOLDIERS AND MARINES DURING
WORLD WAR TWO BACK ACCURATELY
PREDICTING THE INTENSITY OF THE
OCEAN TIDES.
ALLOWING SAFE LANDINGS FOR OUR
ALLIED FORCES DURING THE D. DAY
INVASION OF NORMANDY.
AND LENDING HIS EXPERTISE TO THE
U. S. NAVY THE COUNTER GERMAN
SUBMARINE ATTACKS.
AFTER THE WAR DOCTOR MARK
RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA AND
EARNED A DOCTORATE O
OCEANOGRAPHY AT UCLA.
DR MARK WAS KNOWN TO COLLEAGUES
FOR THE SHEER JOY AND EXCITEMENT
HE FOUND IN HIS WORK AND THAT
ENDLESS CURIOSITY FUELED A
GROUNDBREAKING CAREER THAT TOOK
HIM AROUND THE WORLD MANY TIMES
OVER.
AND LASTED MORE THAN EIGHTY
YEARS FROM HIS POSITION WITH
SCRIPTS INSTITUTION AND HIS HOME
BASE IN LA HOYA DR MARK PLAYED
AN INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN THE
FOUNDING OF UC SAN DIEGO.
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY HE WAS ELECTED TO
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX AND TO THE
ROYAL SOCIETY OF LONDON IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX HE WAS
AWARDED THE PRESTIGIOUS.
GUGGENHEIM FELLOWSHIP THREE
TIMES.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE HE WAS
AWARDED THE PRESIDENT'S NATIONAL
MEDAL OF SCIENCE THE NATION'S
HIGHEST AWARD FOR LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT IN SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH.
AND UNTIL THE VERY END DOCTOR
MARK WAS STILL CONDUCTING HIS
RESEARCH IN THE LATEST CHAPTER
OF HIS CAREER HE TURNED HIS
FOCUS. TO THE EFFORTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE PARTNERING WITH POPE
FRANCIS AND THE DALAI LAMA TO
URGE SWIFT AND DECISIVE ACTION.
DOCTOR MONTHS LEGACY LIVES ON IN
SO MANY WAYS FROM HIS IDEAS AND
HIS GROUND BREAKING RESEARCH TO
THE LASTING SUCCESS OF SCRIPTS
INSTITUTION.
EVERY STUDENT AND LET ME TELL
YOU YOUNG STUDENTS MILLENNIALS
WHEN HE WALKED INTO THE ROOM.
THEY WERE JUST MESMERIZED
MESMERIZED IT WAS AMAZING WE
COULD ONLY HOPE AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
THAT PEOPLE WOULD LOOK AT US
THAT WAY [inaudible]
A WELL.
I HE CONTINUED TO WORK AT UCSD
AND SCRIPTS THROUGH TWO MARINE
SPECIES NAMED AFTER HIM DOWN TO
THE TECHNOLOGY WE USE TO HELP
SURFERS.
YES SURFERS FIND AND CATCH THE
BEST WAVES.
AND OF COURSE HIS MEMORY LIVES
ON THREE SURVIVING FAMILY HIS
DAUGHTERS ET AND KENDALL THREE
GRANDSONS WALTER LUCIENNE AND
MAXWELL.
AND HIS SPOUSE OF TODAY MERRY
COAKLEY MY I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN
ME IN REMEMBERING THE EXTRA
ORDINARY LIFE IN THESE WONDERFUL
STORIES OF DR WALTER MARK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS WITH A
DISTINGUISHED CAREER AND
EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE.
ANY OTHER CHURN IN MEMORIES ARE
THERE ANY OTHERS.
SEEING NONE AND IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT WHAT A WHAT
A LONG AND PRODUCTIVE WEEK.
WE WILL RECONVENE NOT ON MONDAY
BUT ON TUESDAY AT TWO PM I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU THEN HAVE
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND.
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE RECONVENE TUESDAY.
AT TWO PM